لماذا يتعين على سيرينا
ويليامز
استعارة هذا التحذير المشؤوم هيوستن
لدينا مشكلة بدلاً من حالة طوارئ
في الفضاء كانت سيرينا تعاني من حالة طوارئ لعدم وجود
مساحة كافية هيوستن لدينا مشكلة
بعد 5 أشهر من إنجاب طفلها الثاني،
تشارك الفتاة البالغة من العمر 42 عامًا المشكلة  التي
يمكن لأي شخص أن يتصل بها معظم الأمهات الجدد عمليًا، سأكون قادرًا على
ملاءمة هذا عندما لا يكون لدي
بطن لا أستطيع ملاءمته، لدينا طريقة للذهاب يا
فتاة، هذه هي الغنائم التي يدفعها الناس
مقابل LOL الاحتفاظ بها  يحصل الجسم على تنورة جديدة،
تنورة فالنتينو بقيمة 3800 دولار، تقول سيرينا إن
هدفها الآن هو ممارسة التمارين في صالة الألعاب الرياضية
بما يكفي لتناسبها. كان الأمر
يشبه إلى حد ما حلقة الأصدقاء عندما
لم يتمكن روس من ارتداء بنطاله الجلدي مرة أخرى
على الرغم من رشه.  مسحوق ودهن
نفسه
بالغسول تمامًا كما في حالة سيرينا،
فهما لا يأتيان على رجل، لكن المشجعين يلقون
نظرة واحدة على سيرينا ويقولون إن هيوستن
تتجاهل ذلك لا توجد مشكلة، فقد
صنع أسطورة التنس وجوهًا مضحكة وأعاد
التحديثات المستقبلية الضمنية إلى
الدرج من أجل  الآن تعتمد سيرينا على
ضبط النفس بدلاً من التحكم في المهمة،
قل مرة أخرى من فضلك هيوستن، لدينا
مشكلة gimos
CNN New York